hi how surreal is this
here we are it's really weird
we're up here on the wall i know i know
well i actually did like a drawing on a
post-it where i was like
there's not going to be an audience and
it's just going to be us
let's go like blade runner big screen
little me
i love it good idea um thank you
jamie and annie i'm so excited to speak
with you i'm such a huge fan of your
work and you're in kristen's everything
you put out into the world and
i i want to ask like also
where you two met and
what the spark was not only for
bridesmaids but your collaborations
and then this movie like what
is being a fly on the wall in that room
like
oh god that fly probably has some story
um we met at the groundlings years ago
and um we
just were like comedically
drawn to each other and you know she
makes me laugh more than
anyone i think the person who makes you
laugh
is the missing piece absolutely
i don't think i've ever been able to
like date a man who isn't funny
and if i'm not i guess that didn't work
out after all i'm single
you you catch what i'm saying
speaking of like
the missing piece jamie it's like that
shall silverstein where like the missing
piece meets the big o and then they
start rolling and they become this
perfect circle that can roll
and you just fit right in like a little
pea in the pod did it feel that way
it looks that way it feels that way like
i'm not going to pretend that i i
fit seamlessly into anything that
kristen and annie create because they're
like
geniuses and and i i'm just happy that
they left enough of a little sort of
hole for
this sort of irish person to like
i don't know screw my way in and kind of
like try to make sense of this
insane world that they'd created you
know and that was
that was the joy of every day like just
trying to
a try to keep it together and be
professional when you're faced with
some of the silliest scenarios ever put
to film
um uh but that you know i'd be just like
try to make
these two laugh like for me it was like
forget about the bigger picture in the
audience it was just like if if i can
like
you know hang with these guys to make
them laugh then i feel like i'm doing my
job
and hang you do just to chime in about
jamie
um he did fit in seamlessly
and he's just the he's so funny
um and then we just had the best time
and he was so
game for everything and i mean it's
it was one of the highlights of the
experience for us
um yeah just seeing him go because he's
so funny for sure
um i i got also
a lot of different genres and tones for
it was there anything you talked about
as inspiration
you're come you know you're from the
groundlings and you've got snl
you've written a very like cohesive you
know
movie like bridesmaids what do you put
in the blender when you're making a film
like this
oh my gosh um we kind of talked about
like
um it's like like romy and michelle
meets wayne kind of thing and um
just those sillier uh that sense of
humor that's very
sort of absurd um like a top secret
oh you know um oh do you know what was
the other one that you said
naked gun uh hot shots hot shots part
two
so all the great zucker brothers yeah
because it's true
like if they're pitching you the movie
you know like and you just come to play
like whether it's you're breaking into
song or
there's also a sincerity you're i love
your character and what you chose to do
with him
i think that's what's nice with edgar
cause in a way i i feel like him in a
way that
like he's just sort of the you know
there's a lot of fish
out of water elements happening in this
movie but what's cool about edgar is
like he
he's coming and trying to behave a
certain way and get a job done
but he gets swept up by the madness that
he finds himself in with once he meets
barbara star and that's kind of what my
experience is like
it's like me it's like me coming to be
like hey i'm a like
serious actor i'm but i'm in a comedy
and i'm going to be serious and then
meeting kristen and annie and just being
swept up in their nuttiness
and just going with it and that was the
fun part it totally works
um how are each and all of your children
kristen um
you have your two beautiful babies how
has it been
babies in quarantine which is semi-good
timing but also very difficult
yeah it's a weird it's a weird
time because they can't see um
uh human beings at all and when they do
they're just like
like the truman show i feel like they're
just going to come out in the world and
be like there's more
um yeah
but they're really good they're the i
mean they're the best they're
busy and amazing and annie how is your
family in quarantine and during this
time
oh boy um i have a 14 and a
10 year old and i'm yelling a lot
at them um they're taking it all in
stride
um it's so hard when they're this age
because
they're you know they've had their
they're just more aware
uh of everything that's like what was
before and what's now
and they've the isolation it's it's very
difficult and i just think like um
these kids are really champions you know
right now for
all these kids every we gotta root for
them because they're just
it's tough i think that is so well said
um and jamie you have three kids how are
you guys doing
yeah it's um it's just the mad house and
i feel like the last 11 months
i've had some of the best moments i've
ever had as a parent and some of the
worst
i think i think like most parents feel
like that
oh my god i'm really glad i asked you
guys that because between the truman
show
and the keeping it real and the highest
and lowest
it just is perfectly poetic
and apt now there's so many things i
want to ask you guys
but we're about to go to commercial
break and i
do you mind if i just kick this into
high gear and we like
ask a few questions before the break
sure okay perfect
okay kristen if you could be one kitchen
appliance what would it be
a large spoon
not quite a ladle but just like one of
the bigger ones roger that
jamie do you think there's life on other
planets
probably more life than on our planet
currently
see there's that heart and humor i'm
like oh it's time
um annie what's your go-to midnight
snack
a gallon of ice cream lately that's been
my go-to too and then lee harris just
had to put me in a larger size
pant so that's where that leads
um okay jamie what's your go-to shower
song
oh god uh oh no no no no no don't
say it um
no i i get very musical mine's like oh
yeah you know
it's it's probably sending the clients
steven's on there there we go
oh oh that's
a brother that's a beautiful song jamie
it's sad i like to start my day with
total sadness
build from there yeah kristen what's
your favorite place to be stuck in
traffic in los angeles
by the beach yeah annie where's your
favorite place to get stuck in traffic
in los angeles nowhere i know i'm with
you i hate traffic it's my achilles heel
it takes me down
to like an unevolved awful person and
finally jamie what's your favorite place
to be stuck in traffic um
i'm gonna say uh the wendy's on sunset
yes a fast food drive-through
you